what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba no
I'm John friend so we're gonna watch
today Tyco whitey T's trailer or Jojo
rabbit the official trailer that a
Disney is apparently very excited about
it is hurting approved trailer guys it's
my birthday today so a couple of things
I wanted to tell you I'm going on fandom
entertainment screen junkies news in
just a couple of hours make sure to tune
in probably do a livestream later
ourselves to catch up on some movie news
cuz I was gone all weekend shooting a
short film second thing thank you to
everyone who's checked out our patreon
page over there we do weekly q and A's
as well as TV show reactions stream
along for many shows that includes Cobra
Kai season 2 haunting a hill house
season 1 Gotham did all the stranger
things season 3 Jon recently started up
agents of shield and there are several
shows that we do stream along for and
have reaction highlights for as well so
there's footage included attack on Titan
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood my hero
academia of the movie included as well
Death Note Code Geass just started that
up one punch man season one hunter x
hunter and of course supernatural so
make sure to go check out our patreon
page as soon as you can let's go into
this cute accent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she's kind like a person you two seem to
be getting on Wow partner
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that looks Disney errific yeah looks
like the mouse is gonna love them
they reshot all that stuff with the
children and the cutesy stuff between
them our main character and the Jewish
girl just to you know they have that
small layer pitch-black pro-nazi yeah I
like that trailer more than the first I
like the first trailer but this one got
me a lot more interested it feels more
like a taiko ytt film yeah this hooked
me for a whole movie or as the last one
definitely did feel more like this
teaser for a satire yeah felt like a
really good probably the best SNL had
empty this was like an SNL sketch and
then he made it into a movie or
something that's kind of what it felt
like to me but then you know here you
still got of course all that you know
great satire humor its satire people
trying to get your panties in a bunch
here oh yeah but then no but really
having that having more of that heart
really present and the more that
emotional art for their main character
really present as well when the conflict
that he's probably gonna come into cuz I
it seemed more clear to me that oh who's
being that his imaginary friend is
Hitler he's probably going to have to
come to grips with that as he realizes
you know more and more about humanity
and has more experiences with this girl
that teaches about you know again
humanity yeah and you know the fact that
I love that line she says at the end of
this you're not a Nazi you're ten you
just want to you want you want to feel
like you belong and you want to be a
part of a club and wear a funny uniform
and I feel like for a lot of people that
is kind of how you get roped into a
situation like this or indoctrinated
into a situation that's how we got
involved in YouTube John that's exactly
we just want to be a partisan so we just
want to be a part of it all the cool
kids were doing
anytime also Scarlett Johansson's accent
yeah about it that just some reason the
work of the mind is that's a cute accent
go to Germany never her and you very
very urban accent sounds cute maybe
because I'm aware of Scarlett Johansson
doing this probably you can make
anything cute oh there's something about
like the way Sam Rockwell and Scarlett
Johansson are doing their accents that
don't seem like they're yeah I feel like
there needs to be a sense of like it's
not entirely realistic especially for
Sam Rockwell it needs to feel a little
bit heightened so they can get away with
some of the humor one as opposed to
really embodying a you know a German
Nazi character you know I feel like
there may I don't know if this is
intentional although I feel like there
is a stereotype that the German accent
and German language in general is very
harsh sounding and so I wonder if
there's almost an effort here to make
the accent itself lighter and more not
appeal none to say that but the you know
just more soft in the ear or something
to heighten with again that satire
because also you do associate that
accent with a lot of the subject matter
they're gonna be doubting here even
though I am fully aware that this is
satire and even though there is the more
of that heartfelt storyline that they
were teasing here there still is a fine
line you do have to ride dealing with
this subject matter that you're actually
going into world war ii territory you do
have to be you know a little bit
delicate to not cross a certain line and
the way the performances are being
handled with those characters and
remember if we actress all rebel Wilson
in this one yeah yeah a little bit the
book-burning yes all these different
things you associate with Nazis and just
you know groups like the Nazis being
filled yeah just like all these children
for whom it's just Boy Scout activities
yeah and then you captured all through
the eyes a main character is Jojo right
yeah but after all through the eyes of
Jojo who is questioning all this in a
kind of like humorous deadpan kind of
Manor yeah I think you can get away with
a lot of this you ratted on me I feel
like this is gonna be a really funny
film yeah I wonder what poignant points
they're gonna be making about it you
know hey it's not a Nazi funny this this
feels like a Wes Anderson movie in a lot
of ways - yeah I can definitely glean
some of those aesthetic you know types
and things like that especially because
- it's it's more period think about I
don't have the greatest working
knowledge of Tycho itt's like deep cuts
but I feel like they're mostly in a
present day or something close to that
this feels nothing like for Ragnarok the
old movie this definitely filled me with
I mean I had faith just hearing what it
was about and who was behind it but
especially as compared to the first
teaser which was neat I actually got
really dazzled by this and this made me
really want to see the film as soon as
possible because this this gave me that
feeling of this could be heartfelt and
fun and also very timely and kind of the
perfect again little satires so I'm
really rooting for this I hope this does
well and I think yeah that those heart
elements I hope can kind of bring the
people around who don't seem to
understand what this movie is going for
because we have at least a couple
messages from our last trailer reaction
basically be like how could you support
a movie like this I'm like you you must
you did really well and that's people
for you yeah satire and sarcasm mercury
else I mean some people probably do get
genuinely offended I feel like some
people also like doesn't feign offense
as well a solid sometimes it's just you
know pretended just in case I I do think
though that at the end of the day that
when this is one of those films that
probably has more controversy
surrounding a taste-off of marketing and
subject matter as opposed to when you
watch the actual film and you walk out
and you go oh that's not as being a bit
steely nice yeah it's okay so that's why
it's fine guys internal you know well
what do you think of Joe Joe rabbit I
also think this would be good for Fox
Searchlight because they could use like
a bonafide hit on their hand
and I don't know this will be a hit but
I think you know having the some of the
stars behind it inhabit Aiko's name
Marvel director - Marvel stars rebel
Wilson Logan star already or not might
be a good way anyway hey critical
reviews matter a lot to the Royce office
alright guys well thank you for being
here
keep a lookout might do a livestream
later make sure to check me out on
Phantom entertainment later on today I
don't know what we're talking about I
need to get my brain power ready you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell we'll catch
you guys soon